[Music]
you have a treble clef yeah you're a
teardrop yeah did you kill a musician
did you kill an old-timey composer I
killed a few NZ's in my day you know
what you battle rap not really
I don't really bat around you thugs you
I understand I wouldn't want a battle
rap it's it's tense yeah really is
people you barely know being like and
then everyone in the crowds like I don't
I don't need that my day yeah I have
heartburn just from this I actually have
bad heartburn to acid reflux yeah it's
uh I got a pair of a pack of tones in my
back that I would recommend instead of
your treating the symptoms I would go at
the cause of acid reflux what are we
eating are we eating a Organic
plant-based diet yeah are you yeah you
are not we you
[Laughter]
that was the funniest thing that's ever
happened to me
no the funniest thing never happened to
me dog they just put like a gang of
makeup on me now for like a brownie like
almost you feel like a bird up like the
mark I had on my head so I was like
seven go away did you feel like saying
just let me do me no I'm just like man I
don't really get on TV oh I so let me
let them do t I'm not this can actually
not and my this is a wig they you said
that we'd saved your life yeah you love
the crime man I love it just can't get
enough of it someone got they parents
wouldn't so they're like that yeah
how did Meryl marijuana save your life
um I was a little too antsy I jump
around want to go here I want to be
there once I started smoking weed I just
want to stay and play the video game so
you spent good time with your daughter
man after you go smoke go chill with
your daughter you know what I mean you
willing to do whatever she wanted to do
like whatever is done you know
whatever let's go you want to go here
come on like eating play-doh yeah let's
do Bob spongebob squarepants is suddenly
really funny I'm not I'm not a biggie I
am Biber of the of the weed smoke but I
bet you're a hoot to take it in with did
I say that in a way with flavor yeah
just make sure you say pause you don't
opposed to talk with another dude say
take it in I did see that as a mistake
that's like a rapper thing like we say
pause and stuff like that pause yeah
what do you mean PA USA would you stop
oh you stop instead of saying something
stupid you know the rev line but I
didn't mean that but yeah it was PA USC
what was the what was the rap line
[Music]